so I asked Rachel ahead of time I was
like do you want to see avatars three
hours and she was like hell no I don't
want to see that Rachel just can't sit
in a movie she cannot sit in a movie for
three hours I just it's not gonna happen
so I said to her would you mind if I go
with my friends and watch a movie she
was like yeah I'm not gonna watch it
okay so then it's like I'm at The Comedy
Store in Hollywood and it's like 10 30.
it's late so my boy Owen says yo man
let's go see Avatar I talked to my wife
and you know so you know he's married
with two kids and he got it he got out
of that and he's like yo let's go see a
10 45 p.m showing of the movie so Rachel
has to work really early so I text her I
go babe I know you're sleeping but I'm
gonna go check out this movie Avatar
this might be a good time to see in your
sleep right when I get home it's like
she's getting up to go to work okay
because she gets up early because she
has to get ready so she gets like an
hour and a half before she needs to
leave so she's she's up you know it's
like 2 30 in the morning and she's
getting up I'm walking in I said I'll
make coffee for you so I make coffee now
she starts going in she's like oh you
went to the movie without me like you
what you don't even want to you don't
even want to go see this movie and she's
all like yes I did I'm gonna go see it
she always does this man she always acts
like oh I was gonna go see Avatar me and
my girlfriends are gonna go see it oh
really you and your girlfriends are
gonna go see Avatar okay okay Rachel you
I can't wait for that you know she
hasn't gone to seen it yet so I was like
I know you didn't want to see this movie
you just imagine I was out having fun
without you it was just a fun thing
between us and then you know then you
know she hasn't talked about it since
because I know she ain't ever gonna go
watch Avatar even if it's on cable and
we watch it on the TV she ain't gonna
watch it
[Music]